Good afternoon, everyone. Welcome to the 2026 AACR Annual
Business Meeting of Members, and I would like to call
this meeting to a start. I've always wanted to do this
.
And I would like to welcome our CEO, Dr.
Marge Foti, to the microphone to start this meeting.
Thank you.
Well, good afternoon, everyone. It's exciting to
be able to give you a rundown on what we've been doing over the
past year. And all I can say is
we're crazy busy, but having a great time advancing
cancer research. So thank you, Dr.
Su, for an incredible year.
I want to say we've had a fantastic year, and we appreciate your
time very much. So this is my catalyst slide, which I've always shown over
the years, how we are the catalyst for advancing progress,
for improved patient care. And,
we really use all the sectors to be able to get our work done.
So you'll see that we are connected to government, industry,
societies, philanthropic organizations, advocacy groups,
and academia, and cancer centers.
Actually, on route to this meeting,
I ran into two advocates who were so thrilled to be here
and, I mentioned that we are
seriously considering
doing a patient advocate council, and they were just overjoyed.
So we have a lot of work to do with that particular sector as we grow
that area. So
we're very happy that our work is really fostering not only cancer science and
medicine, but really making a big difference, to change the
face of cancer for all populations.
So I want to thank our officers and board of directors for their
amazing work over the past year,
and say that I cannot
do without them. They have been fantastic in guiding us along the way,
to really grow our programs and respond to the needs of the community.
And, the individuals in boldface are those who are
leaving office, and I will acknowledge them in a little while, but
I just wanted to say how amazing it has been to work
with them and for them
to advance our work in cancer research.
This board, which has been elected by the general membership,
is a broad-based board, scientifically and clinically, and it's
always amazing to see them
interact and really come up with some fabulous new ideas.
We've had pediatric cancer, represented in
Charlie Roberts, and last year also Kim Stegmeyer, and of
course, lung cancer. A whole bunch of areas that are
very important to our work.
We also want to thank our foundation board of trustees.
They are growing in number and in impact.
And
there's an amazing excitement in the opportunities there are to raise additional
monies for cancer research, which we desperately need,
to be able to fund more research grants through ACR funds,
specifically along with funds that we would be
really combining with other organizational funds.
So we want to thank them, especially Steve Ryan, and I know that
Dr. Colagiorri will be mentioning him as well.
And we have two new trustees in Steve Crystal,
as well as
Dr. Hite, whom you know very well. And we're very happy
that they are joining this foundation board because
of their wisdom and their excitement about the mission of the
foundation will be really terrific in an
effort to raise more money for cancer research.
And, I don't know what happened. Yes.
I thought I had a slide on the two of them, but I don't apparently. But Mr.
Crystal
is a very interesting person. He lives in Reno, and he's had
a lot of interactions with a number of other foundations, for
which he's raised a lot of money. So he's very enthusiastic and has already
given us a major gift in the first few hours of his
membership on the board of trustees. So we're very grateful.
So, you'll see in this membership list that we
are growing rapidly. Our current
numbers are at a level of 65,014 members
in six individual membership categories in 143 countries and
territories. And what I think is fascinating about this is that
you'll see that the numbers are going up very rapidly.
We had an interesting thing happen, just
earlier this year when, and in just a couple of months,
the numbers went from 62,000 to 65,000 plus.
So I think what's happening is that the word is getting out, particularly
in other countries outside the US, that we are
really the most important cancer research organization in the world, and
everybody wants to join. And there's a lot.
You can see in the blue area, there's a lot of interest among the young
investigators. So, that's a category that is very
important that we have to watch. And you'll see that,
they represent just under 56% of the membership,
and that's in the US alone. But when you
count associate members and student members who are also
undergraduate students and high school students, it goes up to
62% of the US membership and over 64%
of the international membership.
This really puts an enormous responsibility on us to do
more to keep them in the saddle in terms of what we do for the
future. And we're trying to raise funds for their
research grants, but also, education training is
expanding in the AACR. The fellows of the AACR Academy,
that whole body is growing to 399 fellows, and
we're very happyThat Dr. Fuchs
has worked very hard as president and is really trying
her best to raise money through the
fellows of the AACR Academy,
which was originally an idea that Dr.
Jaffe had about having a special fund coming out of the fellows of the
academy. And so that's working out very well.
But suffice it to say that this group consists of
many leading researchers around the world.
We have
just under 400 fellows, but that number is
growing rapidly. We really try to keep it around 24 new
ones every year. But indeed, we could even increase that number
if we wanted to. In any event, it's the 14th class of fellows.
They were inducted
the other night.
They were medaled, and they're very excited. It was a beautiful event.
You can see photographs here of them, and they range not only, as
I said, in the US, but also
abroad. You'll see Dr. Lotai was one of them.
He asked me was he given the fellowship because he's the NCI director,
which is absolutely not correct, because his name was put on
the ballot long before he
became NCI director. And others that are really
leading the way, either both on our board, like
Alice Shaw and Charlie Roberts and Ross Levine.
Lots of interesting
individuals who will contribute in a very major way to the
AACR. Now we have three constituency
groups that have been in existence for a number of years.
The first one
that was formed in 1988.
Over 27,000 members in that group, and they're committed to really
fostering scientific achievements and career development of
women. And they've done a very good job in keeping the focus on that.
And you probably saw the numbers in my slide.
It's almost 45% of the membership who are women, and
in the old days was only 14%. So we are really doing
well there. And as you know, about half of the graduate schools and
medical school applications are from women.
So we're tracking that. And I never mentioned it, but
AACR received an award for having the largest
proportion of women in our leadership vis-a-vis all other cancer
organizations. So I was very honored to
receive that award, and we have to maintain that
image. Associate Member Council is celebrating its 30th
anniversary this year. This was established in 1996,
at the recommendation of Dr. Lee Wattenberg, who was past
president of AACR, and they're doing very well in really
recommending things that can be done for them.
And these are considered early career scientists, but they move
on to become junior faculty, and that's why we are
anxious to work on an early stage investigator council, which
is for junior faculty,
and help them advance their careers to senior roles.
So, this group of
young scientists will need a bylaws change for that, which we'll invoke this year.
But suffice it to say that this is a really exciting opportunity
to keep these people in the saddle before they become more
senior investigators and active members in our membership.
And Minorities in Cancer Research was established in the year 2000.
Over 9,400 members, and also obviously
working hard to
respond to the professional needs of minority scientists, and
that's going very well as well. So congratulations to the
50-year members. We just had a wonderful breakfast
with the 50-year members this morning.
There were only a few who
attended the meeting, three actually, who attended the meeting
that we had this morning. They are not here at this particular...
I think they're all going home. But
there were a number of 50-plus members who were there,
and we had a wonderful discussion about what they can do to help the
field. And I want to thank Dr. Su and Dr.
Collerury for giving wonderful presentations that I
think were really quite spectacular and memorable.
So we have to thank our members
for their support and their long-term interest in the AACR.
Now as you know, we have about 40-plus subfields that we
track, and this is just an overarching slide that you can look at
at your leisure. We're trying hard to keep abreast of what
is needed to be done in our field. And there are
a few new areas like convergence cancer science,
and we're looking at what we can do with that particular group.
But suffice it to say that chemistry is a very active
area of our interest, as you know. DNA damage and repair, we've had
meetings in that space. And early detection
interception,
especially in difficult diagnosis treat
cancers and early onset cancers are high on the list of interests.
And having just come out of the special conferences committee meeting
led by
Dr. Tim Yap, I think that we know that there are areas
here that need attention and that in fact metabolism, right,
Dr. Yap, was very actively discussed during your meeting
a little while ago. So lots to do in terms of meeting the
expectations of the members and trying to see where, in
these cases, where the integration can take place.
We're having a wonderful annual meeting, and
I can give you an updated number. My staff tells me now it's
22,911 people
registered. 97% are actually
here in San Diego.And as you can see, we
have beat the Chicago number, and we're
heading rapidly toward beating the 2024 San Diego
number, which was over 23,000. I think it's
amazing that we have even as much as
22,911, considering
the turmoil in the world right now in terms of what's going
on.
I also think we can let you know that since
we're on the West Coast, it's much more convenient for our members in
Asia, and so we have an uptick in the membership
there. A little bit of a downturn in the
European attendance, but not much.
So I think we're doing well, and I'm very, very happy.
And of course, this is a spectacular meeting with amazing
numbers of abstracts, including late-breaking abstracts,
and 269 clinical trials. We were told we would never get one
trial, and now we have 269 that we're presenting in
various aspects of their development, and wonderful innovation throughout the
whole meeting. So I just want to thank Doctors Michelle and
Shaw for their amazing work. I think there's no question that
they have worked tirelessly to really
offer us an amazing meeting that everyone is enjoying.
And you'll see the entire list of co-chairs.
And also,
in color there, you'll see the members of the Education Committee
and members of the Clinical Trials Committee, who really did a great job
in reviewing all of those
clinical trials and
really did a wonderful job to prepare the education
program, which is a blockbuster. I heard a lot about our
education session this year. And also here, I hope you
are enjoying the presentations given by our
awardees, most of whom were actually for the
first time presented here. There are a couple from
2025, but mostly 2026
awardees, and just fabulous opportunities to hear what they
have to say and what they are recommending for us to do going
forward. We have a very long list of
meetings, but this is just a short list of the 2026 scientific
conferences. Dr. Yapt was just looking at
2027 and beyond. I think it's clear, based on that
special conferences committee group, that there are lots of great ideas that we
need to pursue in terms of addressing the growing needs
because the science is moving very rapidly in all areas,
including technology, early onset cancers, et cetera.
So I think that we're going to see a large uptick.
But also we did talk, if I may mention, Tim, that
we talked a little bit about having some fast-track meetings,
whether it be online or in person, to address what might come out of this meeting,
for example, in terms of the very hot
aspects of science that are presented.
So we'll work on some new themes, but
currently you can see there are lots of great meetings that are happening this
year, and will continue into the future.
The one that I wanted to mention specifically is the
AACR Drug Discovery and Development Conference that our colleagues
here, our officers, and colleagues on the board have
all really worked very hard on. That will be held in July,
and it's really already obviously
has confirmed speakers from industry, but also lots of
exciting new content that will be attractive not only to
pharma, but biotechnology professionals.
And
I think this is a new item. We're going to see how it goes and see how many people
will register for this. But it really is an
exciting opportunity to do more in the area of cancer
therapeutics. We have other collaborative conferences with
organizations.
One is actually
taking place right now
in Lugano, the International Prostate Cancer Symposium.
We have a
relationship with them where Charles Sawyers is over there giving
a wonderful prostate cancer
presentation in the opening lecture, which we have
actually sponsored. ICML and Lymphoma, we're doing lots of other
things in other areas of other organ sites.
And we'll be doing more and more in Singapore and in
Korea as we move forward to
open our office in Singapore.
This one,
the EORTC NCI-AACR meeting, will be in
Barcelona. We're thrilled about that, and I think it's going to be a fantastic
meeting. And, of course, our regular San Antonio Breast Cancer
Meeting, which is the biggest and most impressive
meeting in the world in breast cancer.
This meeting, by the way, we have contributed greatly to
its,
how shall we say, becoming more sophisticated in terms of
production. And as a result,
the exhibits have been expanded by our staff, and
the meeting is now attracting well over 11,000 individuals
from all over the world who are interested in breast cancer.
Educational workshops are starting to grow.
And I think you should know that we have opened a
education division that will not only help
with many of these,
but also devise new topics that need to be addressed.
In light of what we've said, we need to do more for our young investigators, but
even just keeping abreast of the changes in the
world that you live in in cancer science and medicine.
I'm excited to mentionDr. Larusso's
efforts to expand education in Africa in
particular. And we are now actually
already engaged with the credo workshop, which
is actually a bit of a clone of our VEIL course, and we are
now functioning
to increase our activity there. There will be an AACR
representative on that workshop
committee, but especially thank
Dr. Larusso for her focus on clinical research in
Africa. And frankly,
we know how needed it is. But also they'll be discussing clinical
trial design and clinical research.
And also what is interesting about this workshop in
particular, and others that will be devised under her leadership,
will attract not only oncologists, but nurses, pharmacists,
clinical trial coordinators, and other healthcare professionals.
Something that we don't currently do in this part of the world, but
obviously something they need. So we are talking with colleagues
at Memorial Sloan Kettering and elsewhere about collaborating on this.
We also have a very robust AACR On Campus
program now that is really being led by Dr.
Jaffee as the head of the Global Affairs Committee.
This is an important outreach, and
some of you know that we've been
running around the world trying to spread the word about the importance
of cancer research and treatment.
The past events have been in India and also
Brazil,
and also, obviously, Kuala Lumpur,
and Taiwan also. And thank you very much, Dr.
Su, for your efforts to foster those
areas,
foster the interactions with colleagues in those areas of the
world. Selected for this year, in August will be Poland, and
we have some people from the Ukraine who've already come up to me and
given me a big hug for this particular one
to be done in August. And then Colombia and South Africa will
finish out the year with wonderful opportunities.
These are opportunities for training that are
co-funded by the local community.
So I think one should be very happy about that relationship.
We have 10 wonderful journals.
We're very happy that Dr.
Levine has just become a co-editor-in-chief
of Blood Cancer Discovery.
What will happen here is that Dr. Cantley will rotate off in June,
and we're very happy to say that
Dr. Matthew Vander Heiden will take
that spot in terms of basic translational research.
And
also as you see here, there are new editors of
cancer immunology research in
Doctors Jaffee and Ribas, two past presidents who are going to be
leading this journal into the next decade. And thank you, Dr.
Yapp and Dr. Su and everyone else who contributes to this
very important array of great journals in our field.
We have a number of task forces, and I just wanted to quickly mention a couple.
Dave Tuveson during his presidency formed the exploratory IND
biomarker-driven clinical trials one.
It was interesting. It kind of paused that exploratory
IND part, and all of a sudden, we started to consider how we can
launch our first clinical trial.
And so I have a slide on that, but I wanted to mention that the
brainchild of that was this whole group who said,
"Okay, let's pause the exploratory IND and really go forward
with AACR starting its own clinical trials." And
so we are working on that.
We have a great
imaging and theranostics task force led by Keyvan
Shakari. And
also the Asian/Asian American task force, that Native American task
force has been very interesting. Dr.
Pal has been leading that for now three years.
We noticed that our membership has 35%,
35% of the 65,000 members are actually either Asian or Asian
American, which shocked us when we looked into that
number. And so we said, "Wow, then they have to be in leadership
as appropriate." So by some minor tweaks
and
consideration of these individuals, we have
really upped that, and we're so happy
that some changes for considering demographics
has really changed this picture. And we can now be very happy
and say many more people are being considered for the board of directors, as
president, as committee chairs, and so on.
So that's working very well. The trust in science task force will
probably be terminated, and there will be a
standing communications committee that will take on the role of ensuring that
trust in science continues. And I wanted to mention that
what was amazing was that we did a poll
last year, a bipartisan poll, and we found that
89% of the public is very anxious that
biomedical research be supported and increased, and
83%, they want cancer research
definitely supported and increased.
So I think it's going to be important that that committee and that education
of the public continue. We're not disbanding this only
because we feel it's completely done, but
because it's a broader... area of our
concern. Immuno-oncology will be having its task
force meeting here,
as will lung cancer. Aging and cancer had a fantastic
think tank, and they will have their own meeting in 2027.
We're having a meeting of the Cancer Data Task Force, Data Science
Task Force, this afternoon. And two new task forces
that are
actually being built under the leadership of Dr.
Su are in surgical oncology with Dr.
Yaffe as the chair, and biostatistics in cancer research,
Dr. Yushar. These are all new initiatives, these two,
but others that are being strengthened.
And I think that we'll see some fabulous ideas coming out of this group.
We also have 10 scientific working groups, and you know that the reason
these are
there is because these groups initially felt underrepresented in
the AACR, and they appealed to the board for a working group, the first one being
in 1999. However, now during the strategic
plan, we need to really think about, what about the other areas?
Because these have been very, very successful.
You can see that
over 20,000 members signed on to the Tumor Microenvironment group.
That's certainly not underrepresented at this point.
So there are ways to consider how we can foster what all
these areas need,
but also see what areas are missing in this list.
And the newest is Hematologic Malignancies with
2,400 members. There are actually 6,000 blood
cancer experts in our membership, and pathology and cancer research.
So, I'll keep you posted, but suffice it to say that this is
an area that will change in the development of the strategic
plan. I'm very happy to say that Project Genie is moving very
well with more than 265,000 sequenced samples
in the registry.
More on that at another time. Cancer Progress Report
series is also growing. This first one, the broad-based one, was
done in 2011. But we have now,
as a result of our proactivity, been launching cancer disparities reports.
We had a wonderful pediatric cancer progress report, which was
new, first of its kind, was delivered to Congress in December
2025, and one that we'll be working on in blood cancer research in
2027. I want to also mention, Dr. Heidt, who's here
today, has, as you know, become our chief scientific
advisor. He is leading a scientific advisory council that will
report to the board of directors on new frontiers.
They're looking at all these areas, and I won't go into great detail other than to
say that this has been a fabulous undertaking with about 50
SAC members from various fields and demographics who have really
been giving a lot of thought to the scientific priorities that our
organization needs to foster. And you will receive a
report from it when it gets finalized, but suffice it to say that
there are some topics that have really reached the top, like early detection and
prevention, interception, immunotherapy, et cetera.
So we'll keep you posted, but it's been an exciting thing to work on and
will continue throughout the year.
And also we have, over time, increased our grants
program to
respond to the needs of the field. You'll see it's gone up dramatically.
Of course, this money does include Stand Up To Cancer grants, but it's
more than $551 million that we have administered
to 3,400 scientists in the US and abroad, and I think it's
32 countries abroad. And I think it's going to be increasingly important
to see how much more money we can raise.
Stand To Cancer's grant portfolio has gone down
considerably because of their
lack of effort to try to
raise more money. But at the same time, ours is going up.
And I have to say that our relationship with the Mark Foundation
has been a great
activity that we've had. One such very new grant
program is the AACR Mark Foundation Chemistry in Cancer
Research grant program. It is a co-funded
activity that will fund 150K per
year for a total of $450,000 per
grant for three years. A wonderful
new program that we're very excited about.
And of course, you heard this morning--
Let's see, it's Monday. Sunday morning,
the AACR Trailblazer Cancer Research grants
consist of $15
million worth of grants
to be given to 15
worthy individuals, nine early stage, and six
mid-career. I was talking to our representative from Pfizer last
night and informed him we're so excited because that money, that $15
million,
really came out of that generous donation
to us. And that was a strong recommendation of Dr.
Greenberg, and I'm glad that this could be realized.
And of course,
the committee was outstanding and working extremely hard
to
read, review, and decide on 15 grants out
of over 500 submissions. Just amazing.
So I want to thank that group for working so hard.
And then we have a new one that was also announced
yesterday, the AACR Torrey Coates Foundation
Trans-Pacific Gastric and Esophageal Cancer
Research Partnership grants. This is also interesting
because it's one US-based PI and one
Asia-based co-PI. So we'll see how this goes,
but this first group
was selected also by a very rigorous process,
and we're very happy to see the fruits of their
labors in terms of the ideas that have come forward.
And I know
that people here have worked very hard to try to make those
decisions as well.Now we had a meeting yesterday of the Cancer Centers
Alliance, also along with Dr. Lotai, that went
very well. This is just a historic slide to show you that
it was launched in 2023 in the fall.
There are now 99 cancer centers signed on.
That is higher than what we had originally, which was 94.
They're very anxious to do more. Dave Tuveson did a fabulous job
in
presenting what we've done with that group to date, and
we will
be telling you more and more about that over time.
But there are four subcommittees.
One just recently formed on AI and data science with Shirl
Willman and Matthew Vander Heiden as co-chairs.
But also, of course, we're looking at all areas of
science and education training. So more on that very
soon. And the Rally for Medical Research continues to urge
policymakers to prioritize NIH research.
The Rally
Hill Day,
which will be taking place in September, will be, again, a blockbuster.
But I wanted you to know that it consists of 400 organizations representing
millions of people around the country, going
to
Congress to pitch for more medical research for
all diseases. And we really have
made a lot of good friendships with other organizations in the biomedical research
space, so this has been extremely helpful, and it will help us
get the point across. And this research on the road idea
is one that will go beyond the four states which we are
working on now to make sure that locally, the
leaders, the senators, and congressmen, bipartisan, understand
the importance of cancer research.
Of course, we're all over the world.
We have a lot going on, and I'm very proud
of it. A third of the members are from outside the US, so we have to do that and
have to make sure that we really are doing a sufficient
amount of work in various areas. I've mentioned Africa.
Australia, we just got back about a month or so ago from
Melbourne, and all the cancer center directors from all over the
country flew to Melbourne to meet with me and Fred
Biemer to discuss how we can do more
with them. So I think there are lots of opportunities, and we'll keep you posted
on that. And as some of you know already, we are opening up our office
this year in Singapore to really strengthen what we do in the
Asia-Pacific region. Now, this is, I believe, my last
slide. I wanted to
tell you that we are working on a strategic plan, and many of these things
we've been trying to ask and consider when we think about
the challenges ahead in terms of keeping us abreast,
keeping us very hot in terms of science, but also
responding to the needs of the community.
And we have had visionary leadership at the board, committee, and staff levels,
and we have to maintain that. So that's one area that is going to be very
important. We'll be continuing to hire staff
to be able to do that. I was very happy to acknowledge the
three individuals
yesterday morning who've been with us for 25 years, and Mike
Stewart is here as one of the three.
We are very, very proud of what he and others have done.
So we need to do more, though. We need to have more.
So we will do so, and we obviously will need sound judgment and
decision-making, and as Dr. High tells me
repeatedly, we have to know what to do, but also what to eliminate
in terms of our programs. We're working on those decisions.
Novel external partnerships will be needed that contribute to
our mission, and we need to use new technologies to
maximize our productivity and efficiency, including AI
internally. So we'll have to see how that works.
Strong administration. We need more project management, but obviously, in
order to do that, we'll need additional staff and a major increase in
that staff. We're expecting to go from 265 to 300
this year in terms of staff members.
When I started, we had 12, just to give you a sense of the difference in
the number.
And we'll be exploring new strategies for financial stability,
long-term viability, and increased fundraising is definitely on our
list of things to do.
Really needing to continue to innovate and grow
and have really a transformational impact. And I want to thank Dr.
Barker for her hard work on the strategic plan.
There's no question that we will be making every attempt to get to the
end of this plan by the end of the year.
Our plan will unequivocally be the most consequential one in our
long history because of its importance at this particular
time, but also the challenges that are ahead of us in terms of how do
you
respond to the professional needs of 65,000
people in 143 countries? How do you do that?
What do they need? And how can we sustain the
workforce, and make their work very robust?
So this is an important
plan and important committee that's working on it of about 50 people,
too. So we have lots of people telling us
how to do things going forward, and we will be also surveying the
membership. So I want to thank Dr. Sue again for her amazing
leadership as president. It's really been an honor to work
with her.
She's not only a visionary leader, but she also is so
responsive
to our needs. And so
within minutes, will always
respond to a request that I have, and I just can't believe how she's been able to
do that, but I don't think she sleeps.
But anyway, we'll look forward to continuing to have
her as our past president, but also,
as I've told many of them,
and some of them are in the room, once a president, always a president,
and I want to thank her and all of them for their amazing
leadership. So thank you.
Thank you, Marge. I think the honor is all mine to have worked with such a
great organization. So, to give you a
very high-level summary of what I have been doing for the past year,
I think the
one item I'm most proud of, I'm proud of everything, is that we're
establishing the AACR Professional Excellence Program.
If you're able to drop by the sales pavilion right
after this, there's going to be a meet and greet.
This is going to be an exciting program for our early career
investigators. As you might have noticed during the opening
ceremony, I've been traveling quite a bit.
I was in several countries in Asia-Pacific area, really
meeting our investigators, scientists, researchers, and early
career investigators in these countries, including China,
Taiwan, Japan, Korea, to encourage them to come
to our annual meeting, as well as to present their work at our annual
meeting, and also participate in other AACR activities.
And I can feel from this year's meeting, when I meet them,
that they really feel very engaged and very excited about
presenting their cancer science and medicine.
I've been also working with
the AACR team, as well as our various
officers and board of director members on multiple meetings.
Obviously, we have done a workshop with the FDA earlier on
this year, on early endpoints, and the white paper is
in progress, expected to submit to CCR by
the middle of the year. We've obviously been working on this meeting, thanks to
Paul Michiel and Alla Shaw, and you heard about the D3 meeting
from Marge.
We've been also actively engaging various other groups,
including the nurses, Oncology Nursing Society.
Ten of them have been awarded by
a scholarship to come to this AACR, and they've been coming to
multiple meetings with us, and also attending the scientific
program to learn about various aspects of cancer research.
We are going to also work with the surgeons, the surgical oncologists, to make sure
that
they're going to be participating actively in
AACR activities. So as you heard from Marge, we have the Surgical Oncology
Task Force, and we also have established a Biostatistics
in Cancer Research Task Force. These individuals are very important in
clinical trials, and I think we need to make sure they have
a good home for them at the AACR on a regular basis.
So,
under the leadership of Pat LaRusso, we have been working very
actively for the last couple of years to lead
and open the first clinical trial, and not the last for sure,
by AACR. And this is a very exciting study,
because it is a highly, highly impactful
scientific-driven study, is an adaptive biomarker driven organ
preservation study in gastroesophageal cancer.
These are patients that normally will have their esophagus or upper part
of their stomach taken out because of the cancer, and you can imagine how
disfiguring and dysfunctional having that surgery is to
our patients. So the goal of this study really is to see if we
can develop a way to predict who wouldn't need that surgery done,
that we can spare them from this
fairly highly morbid and highly toxic surgery.
So we already have gotten bought in from multiple pharmaceutical
companies as well as diagnostic companies, and we
have plans to activate this study by enrolling the first
patient this year. We already have FDA as well as Health
Canada approval. So very exciting, and as I said, this
is going to be just the beginning of many clinical trials
that I can foresee AACR will be launching.
I've mentioned most of these items already, and Pat is the
leader for our Clinical Trials Advisory Council.
Many of our members are part of this
advisory council to really provide advice to AACR
on really how to
really think of the most important scientific questions to translate it to the
bedside and back to bench.
And
here's our fearless chair, Pat LaRusso, for this task force, for this
advisory council, and as you can see, these are the various members
involved.
The responsibilities, obviously, as I mentioned, in addition to
developing and operationalizing this study,
we're really gathering support from different pharmaceutical
companies, work with the AACR team, especially Jan,
sitting in the audience, as well as Denise, who have been working very hard for the
last couple of years to get this first study open.
And I think it will contribute to this
platform that we have created, and it will just be very much
easier for the second and third trial to come on because the platform is already
built.
Now, I'm going to tell you a little bit about the PEP course, but I hope many of
you will drop by the pavilion later on this afternoon to hear more about it.
There's also a postcard that you can take home to your early career
investigators. Or if you are yourself an ESI, bring one home,
because the call for this program is out, and we
will be launching the RFA very soon in the next few months.
The idea really is to create a workforce
or to continue to encourage our workforce to
become leaders as well as mentors in their own time.
And we are going to empower them with essential skills,
as well as professional excellence so that they can
become excellent researchers, effective mentors, and
institutional leaders.The plan is to engage
up to 20 early career investigators between three to
seven years from their first appointment, and this will span basic
translational, clinical, and population science.
And I think having a hybrid of these different disciplines is a very
unique feature for a program such as this.
There are other leadership development programs, but one that has this kind of
hybrid and mixture is very unique.
And we'll have virtual sessions on a monthly basis with the mentors.
We already have a steering committee as well as mentors, and we also will
have three in-person visits at the headquarters in Philadelphia, where
this group can work together with each other and with experts.
They will have a team project within each team of five, so four teams
of five, on a project that is going to be scientifically
driven. These are going to be their capstone projects.
So hopefully you can help me spread this word out because I think this is an
exciting educational opportunity.
I want to thank Marge, our CEO, as well as the board
of directors, as well as the AACR team. They have become my family.
I am not going to
be joking about this because this is serious.
I talk to them more than I talk to my family.
So it's
going to be sad, bittersweet for me to be
not as frequently engaged, but I will plan to be continuing to be very engaged.
But I think all of us are working hard really because we only
have one enemy. We only have cancer, and we need to do this
obviously for our patients, and cancer affects all of our family and
our friends. So I think we're all united in our goals.
With that, I am going to invite our treasurer to the podium to
give us his treasurer's report. Dr.
Michael Caligiuri. Thank you.
Okay.
Good to see everybody. Thank you for joining us for this meeting.
First, we're going to just have a moment of silence for
not only this outstanding gentleman, but for, on the next slide, I'll show you all
of our members that have passed in this last year.
But we wanted to take a moment just to especially recognize Barney
Clarkson, who is at Memorial Sloan Kettering,
director of Hematology and Medical Oncology Training Program, chief of the
Hematology Lymphoma Service. But within our family, within our
organization, was the foundation president and chair for 14
years,
our treasurer from '94 to 2010,
and AACR president from 1980 to
1981. I think perhaps most importantly, Barney
actually selected Marge to lead this organization, so
talk about a brilliant move.
That was the most brilliant move. Very, very special
person. If you've been at AACR, you've known Barney, and he
passed peacefully this year.
In addition, we've lost a number of members
this past year, as you can see on this list here.
A very nice tribute to them earlier in the meeting, but
I think at our board meeting actually as well.
So just take a moment right now of reflection to
remember all that they provided, not only to our organization, but
to each of us as well.
Thank you.
So,
just a quick look at our numbers here, and if you have
questions following my presentation, following this entire
presentation, Mike and Joe are both here and can
direct you through them. But just to point out a couple of things, here was
what in 2025, bottom line here is what we had
budgeted,
and you can see that in fact, in actuality,
we actually finished it with a substantially higher amount of
unrestricted net assets. And there are two reasons for
that. We had a net gain in operations, which I'll explain a
bit on the next slide,
and astounding returns from our investment
income and our spending policy. So these two numbers
themselves really attributed to a
much more projected gain and a much higher
unrestricted net asset at the end of the year.
So we're in really good shape.
Looking now at our 2026 budget, comparing it to the
column I showed you earlier,
you can see that we actually have a planned
change in net assets of about $9 million
here. And the reason for that is we have both the
ADAPTA trial, which Lillian just spoke about to
account for in our budget, which we were going to account for in
2025, but pushed that down to 2026.
And further,
the Trailblazer grants, which were approved in
2025, were going to start. And again, there was a delay, so we have
15 grants at a million each, which will be accounted for in
2026. So taking those two expenditures into account,
we're projecting a solid year, but that'll leave us
with a deficit of about $9 million here.
And you can see that we project
that we'll have remaining net assets of about
$243 million, which is really
remarkable for the last several years due to the
investments and the contributions that we've had.
If we look at this graphically, you can see how
Marge, Mike, Joe, and our board has led us
over the years to this amazing gain in
unrestricted reserves. You can see here we're up$250
million, almost $252 million. Quite a
steady increase over time, which is just
remarkable.
And then if we look at the revenues that we've generated in green,
the expenses that we've had in red, and then what that's left us in
terms of growing our reserves. Again, outstanding
fiduciary guidance here, as we've now got very solid
reserves. And I should say, as the new treasurer, we're just getting started.
So, moving on to sources of
revenue, we're looking to have a transformational
change in our foundation board
activity.
We're led quite capably by Steve Ryan.
He's an amazing new leader bringing staunch commitment,
guidance to really increasing-- He's talking the B word,
and he's talking about it quite seriously, and is
set to help us
build out the infrastructure we need to really push towards
unrestricted assets and endowment that would total
in the billion range. So he's himself a person of
finance. He has
a highly successful financial profession, extraordinary
vision, expertise, and experience in the business itself, as well as strategic.
He himself is a financial advisor, so strategic financial
planning is in his sweet spot, and a great leader.
And we're really looking forward to him to really increase
the commitments we have going into our foundation.
It's an honor to work with him, and we want to publicly acknowledge
his dedication to the AACR and to our mission.
With that, I will introduce the person who, I think at
this moment, is still our immediate past president, Dr. Pat Larusso.
Thank you very much.
If I talk real slow, I'll be immediate past president longer.
Okay,
so I'm going to not do that, though.
Because I
know everybody has a place to go. So, thank you very much
for introducing me. And before I
advance the slides,
I must tell you that being a president of AACR is an amazing experience.
Somewhat of a life-changing experience.
And it opened up many doors, and it really opened up
how I perceive things, not only locally, not
only with the AACR, but globally throughout the world.
So, I have to thank the AACR for affording me that opportunity.
So, I want to introduce the outgoing directors of the AACR
board. There are five of them. They've served each for three years.
John Carruthers, Christina Lovely, Elizabeth
Platz, Alice Shaw, and Jed Wolchok.
All of them really bringing their unique skills and
brainpower and leadership to the board, and we will
miss them significantly. But I have to thank them for
their service.
And we do have newly elected board members, and these are the five people that will
be replacing the five I just previously showed you.
Ross Levine,
who's at Memorial Sloan Kettering, Christopher Lee, Sheila
Studdert, Ashani
Weeraratna, and John Wherry.
And we thank you for accepting the
responsibility of being on the board and helping to
grow the AACR.
We also have newly elected AACR Nominating Committee members.
We have Daphna Barshaczky, John Carpten,
Gordon Mills, and Lisa Newman. Again, four
outstanding leaders, all bringing unique skill sets
to the table to hopefully
select the next few
years of outstanding board and
leadership positions at the AACR
by being the nominating committee.
And with that,
I would like to introduce and bring to the stage
Dr. Robert Vonderheide. Dr.
Vonderheide
will be the incoming
AACR president after Keith Flaherty
serves his reign. But Dr. Flaherty should be--
Well, he's the incoming-- Okay, I'm not going to go
there. But Dr. Vonderheide is the president-elect
designate in about a minute, and
will be replacing Dr. Flaherty in a year. But Dr.
Flaherty has to become the president in the next few minutes.
So with that, thank you very much.
Oh, Lillian.
No, I'm done.
Oh, okay.
Thanks. I just wanted to say
what a great honor it is to now be the president-elect, and one day,
president of the AACR.
I think it's very clear that all of us who are leaders, our job is
to serve our members
and uphold the values of AACR, which is scientific
rigor, collaboration, and impact that matters to our patients
and their families. So, I look forward to working with Keith
and Lillian, and of course, ongoing with Pat and all the other
past presidents of AACR. Thank you very much.
So I just want to, again, reiterate my thank you to AACR for really
being a highlight of my career, and I look forward to continue to be engaged with
the organization. It is my great, great,
great pleasure,
because I'm passing the baton to him
and he'll have a busy year, to introduce my good friend,
Keith Flaherty, who will be our president in 30 seconds.
He is the director of the Henry and Belinda Termeer Center for
Targeted Therapy, Director of Clinical Research in Mass General Cancer Center,
and many more titles, as you can see, Professor of Medicine at Harvard
Medical School. He is an entrepreneur, he is an innovator,
he is a clinical trialist, he is a clinician scientist, and I
think AACR is going to be in a fantastic hands in his
leadership together with Dr. Fodies and the board of directors.
Keith, I think you're supposed to come up and present me my plaque, so I
found my own plaque.
I have to pretend to present it to you.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
And allow me to do this because I wanted to.
This is the transfer of leadership.
This is how it is now,
and this is how it will be now.
It's all yours. Congratulations.
That's a cool slide.
I get to use the gavel already?
Just passing the gavel.
Oh, you're supposed to-
Pass the gavel.
Here.
Please. Do we need a photo of this? Yes.
Yeah, I see.
Perfect. Great.
Okay, I'm just going to use it.
Yeah. That's not in the notes. I just did that.
All right.
Thank you, Lillian.
Thank you.
Yeah. I'm going to make a few comments about
how honored and humbled I am. And then I'm going to shift gears and make a few
comments about
translating my
proposed
presidential initiative, which is
something that I think requires a little bit of translation.
So I will
first, though, say this organization
has been my career-long platform.
And I have a long list of debts of gratitude
that I've really shifted focus, I would say, in these past five years of
my career, to try to create a strategy for paying off those
debts.
I don't think I'll ever be able to pay off this one, though, to AACR.
Because
in the first 10 years of my career, I started my career in oncology
exactly in the year 2000. So nice, even numbers, makes it easy for me
to do the math and update it.
That first decade of the 2000s,
I was a pure taker from the AACR. I benefited so
much. I came to this organization, to the
meetings, and certainly the journals,
to learn the science
and try to meditate on what aspects of that science I would
attempt to try to translate to medicine.
Which was no small task at that time in the field.
And I was doing that work in parallel in melanoma and kidney cancer.
And I had a lot to learn about the underlying biology of those diseases, and it's
this
organization that really began to feed
me with the insights that drove critical
early career decisions.
But fundamentally, it was people that I met at
the AACR, and I'll just briefly reiterate an anecdote that I've
been
telling people at this annual meeting, that it was at
my second AACR meeting was the molecular targets meeting.
I came to the annual meeting in the spring of my first year of fellowship,
and then that following fall, went to the molecular targets meeting.
Doug Hanahan gave a keynote. The keynote
completely spoke to the hypothesis that I was framing
at the time regarding angiogenesis inhibition.
And basically, he proposed a two target
strategy that I wanted to convert into a two drug strategy.
I went up to him after his talk, asked him a series of questions, including, "Is
anyone at UCSF already running with this idea?
Because I don't want to be redundant." He said, "No, absolutely.
Actually, they're not."
And I asked him if he'd be willing to advise me in that
regard, and I was submitting a K award, which this became
the centerpiece, so a trial that I proposed actually through the
NCI and CTEP. So, that
anecdote, just a powerful single example of
how AACR, and the great
benefits of the convening power, if you will, of AACR, and
the downstream consequences, because it had a major catalytic event.
But I want to just build a little bit on that NCI CTEP part and just quickly
connect the dots to the present.
I was focused on drug development as the core center of my
research interest.
I wanted to try to create
a research program
that entailed what I later called bedside-to-bench translational research
concept, in terms of a career in such a thing that needed
some work, to say the least. But it was by going to
NCI CTEP meetings that I met Pat and Lillian,
who, those of you who
know the details of their career, will know that they are just absolute
giants in the field of drug development.
And it's from them that I learned how it's
done. That was really
just a foundational...
you know, mentorship from a distance, that again, ACR,
I think it's one of our missions to be able to do that.
But my relationship with them, my learning relationship with them began
then.
When Marge
informed me that the nominating committee
thought I might be a worthy candidate for president,
I really was somewhat taken aback.
Turned out I wasn't that worthy. Phil Greenberg beat my pants
when I ran a few years ago. But the nominating
committee decided that my humility hadn't been adequately tested,
so they, a couple of years later, decided they thought again I was
a worthy candidate, and I said, "Really? You want me to lose twice?
Okay."
But
I was so grateful for the support of this community in giving me this opportunity
to try to give back and pay back such a massive debt of gratitude that I
have.
I do want to make a couple of comments, though, as I now step into this role.
Marge, I do sleep, to be clear. Very protective of that sleep.
So you might have to wait a little bit into the
morning hours before I will respond,
but I do understand that's part of the role.
But I also want to emphasize that I've also learned that this
massive organization and all that it does is way too complex.
Bob really eloquently stated sort of what the job description is
to try to serve as ACR president and really to try to
represent, and do our very best to
ultimately give the microphone to leaders across all of our research
disciplines and hopefully try to even direct more incremental funding
to them. It's too big a job for one person, and I've learned that this really is a
three-person job, because I grew into it by having the
great benefit of deepening my relationship with these two
giants in my field of drug development, Lillian and Pat,
and I'm super grateful for your mentorship over this past year.
I think I've also learned what may be obvious to all of you, that
this job entails working for Marge Foti.
That's a tough task. But really what it means
is we're trying to tap into her knowledge.
Which I sometimes think of the phrase institutional
knowledge, but that would imply that the knowledge is distributed throughout the
organization. Marge actually kind of just has all that knowledge.
It's impossible to learn all that she knows about ACR and its work
in one year's time. So this year I'm going to accelerate that learning curve.
I'll keep at it in year three, and as I've learned and I'll reiterate in my own
way, I get it, that this is essentially then a permanent
opportunity to try to give back to this organization, and I do take that very
sincerely, because it's not going to be possible for me to deliver
or to pay back that debt in just even
three short years.
So again, thank you all for your support in electing me in the first place and
giving me this opportunity to try to give back to this community that's given me so
much.
Okay, I do want to make a few...
Oh, well, and I think I-- Thank you, Pat, again.
You and I, our relationship's going nowhere by virtue of you stepping out of
this role. But Bob, you're now stepping into this three-person job.
Just again, to reiterate and warn you,
there's some things that are going to show up on your calendar that you probably
didn't know were coming in this president-elect year.
Okay.
So for those of you who read my, I don't know
what we call it, pitch or platform or something, the little blurb that I wrote when
I ran for president the first time and lost badly to Phil Greenberg,
and then updated slightly
when I ran a second time.
I was describing in there,
in a very few words something about the research
program that I built
at Mass General starting 16 years ago,
which was the evolved version of what I refer to as bedside to bench
translational research with therapeutics at the core, particularly
investigational therapeutics.
We have teams upon teams that we've built over time in this very
well-resourced environment, and that's the phrase I want to kind of really
underscore from this
slide.
In collaboration with our interventional radiology colleagues largely, and to a
degree, also with our surgical colleagues, we developed
this serial tumor biopsy truly program.
Multiple
groups within groups here in terms of being able to allow us to be able
to deeply interrogate what was happening in patients' tumors,
minimizing risk to patients who were agreeing to participate in
this rather intensive form of research.
We published on even just this approach in terms of sort of the
feasibility, safety of doing this work.
And to use that to try to understand mechanisms of action and
resistance, so ultimately determinants of response and resistance, and always
pairing that with blood-based assays with the hope that we could try to produce
more portable biomarkers, if you will, because I well understand that
while I do want the most resourced institutions
in the country and around the world to do this work to
accelerate our realization of rational combinations, scaling to the
complexity of cancer rolls right off my tongue, but guess what?
We haven't really done it yet in the field.
We have precious few rational combination therapies.
But I do want to highlight that this approach actually allowed Tony Ribas and
I to realize, a single drug effect of
BRAF inhibitor therapy in melanoma, rather quickly to understand how it
is that melanomas attempted to rebound, pairing MEK inhibitors with BRAF
inhibitors. We did that three times over.
And there was just a three-year gap between the first approval of an effective
single agent BRAF inhibitor and the first approval of a BRAF/MEK combination
therapy. This approach is what was behind
thatAnd so I do think it can actually allow us to climb up
the curve in terms of accelerating advances for patients.
And again, we're quite behind schedule, in my view, in terms of building on some of
our foundational therapies. But this is not for everyone, and it's
resource intensive, obviously, in terms of
sort of technology and approaches. It's very resource intensive in terms of people.
I'm absolutely blessed to have this incredible faculty
who basically spread across the cancer types.
This is just the solid tumor faculty.
We have hematologic
investigators as well doing this work in our
larger program. But this is what we refer to as the Tamir Center, which is more
focused on solid tumors.
And it's this faculty who actually wake up
on nights and over the weekend, come in
to participate with our pathologists in performing rapid autopsies.
Because we weren't going to ask our pathology colleagues to do all that heavy
lifting in support of our efforts to try to understand
determinants of response or resistance to the therapies we were investigating.
And so what I've proposed, which this slide is not going to really
adequately, I think, describe to you, is that we
use some of that
sort of portability strategy that I just described in terms of our research method
to try to do a very hard thing, which is to take
the resources that are available, and by resources, I mean people and
technologies,
at the best funded research programs in the country.
That's what's purple here. That's receipt of the top 10 states
by total NCI funding.
And basically partner with young investigators, we all, I
think, can understand the logic of that, who do work in
under-researched and underserved populations,
and to basically bring resources and mentoring
to those investigators and create teams, and
effectively team science, to close gaps in
disparities. I'm not pretending that disparities
are fundamentally about biology as opposed to social determinants.
That's not my point. But rather, we simply haven't
adequately studied the cancers that occur in under-researched
populations. By definition, under-researched.
And we need to do that. We need to accelerate that work to understand
how to create
more sort of customized therapies, if you will, for all of our patient
populations. These arrows are just to try to conceptualize
sort of the movement of ideas, resources,
mentoring. But don't take that so seriously.
These arrows could point in different directions at different places, and this
ultimately could even be more of a global type of initiative.
I simply want to use AACR's convening power to start to pull our
leaders who do phenomenal work, translational research
work, and disparities work,
obviously our magnificent cancer biology
community.
I want to tap leaders to join me in conversation of how to do
this. How to do this well. That might boil
down ultimately to a single demonstration project where we try to pull
together one team in one region.
But I think there's a feedforward opportunity here, in my view, and I
want to try to use
the years ahead in my career to try to really
take the approaches that we've developed and really build
careers, impact patient populations that I think we've underserved.
So I will close with that.
Again, it's really an honor to step into this
role.
And again, thank you all for giving me that honor.
I'm going to flip through these slides because they're not for today,
and conclude
with a significant part of my work I recognize.
I chaired the program committee a couple of years ago.
And I asked Sheila Stewart and Kurt Schalper to co-chair,
or simply two chairs,
to basically do the work of preparing us
beginning now for next year's annual meeting.
And you all know the critical nature of that for our organization.
It is the foundation upon which so much of our other programming stems.
I'm thrilled at the all-star cast of members
and advisors who've agreed, and we will convene in a little
less than a month's time, in fact, to begin our work of
learning from this year's meeting and its
successes and what opportunities remain in terms of directions that we can go.
So obviously, a critical role. I will not skip over that as I
also try to steward the organization in many other
directions.
Okay. And with that,
new business
that any of you would like to address. Thank you.
Well, I think after.
I think after new business, I'll use the gavel again.
Anyone? No. People really want me to use the gavel, I think.
One more slide.
Okay. Now, meeting adjourned. Thank you all.